boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on we
are in New York City New York we are
currently at the Suzy offices we are
talking to Matt Britton what's up man
what's up man good to see you thanks for
coming on the show thanks for coming by
yeah it's such an honor because Matt is
in my opinion the world's leading
millennial and Gen Z expert and just
just a plethora of insight around
consumers and consumer insights and and
where we're moving yeah and I'm super
grateful for this conversation we're
gonna be taking it all over the place
another little bit on Matt's background
as he also has consulted for over half
of the fortune 500 companies over the
last 20 years he's the author of the
best-selling youth nation which was
number one on Amazon business book list
he's an entrepreneur in the digital
social media marketing services with mry
which was acquired and now Suzy a
consumer intelligence software platform
and we're gonna talk about getting these
real-time consumer insights we're going
to talk about what's going on in this
hockey stick of exponential technology
and population that's going on so let's
jump into it do it let's do it okay
Maddie B yes
tell us about your current thoughts on
humanity because we're human animals we
found ourselves as stewards of earth and
current thoughts on humanity very
existential place yes I mean I think you
know I don't think asked about
Millennials are they more socially
conscious than Gen Xers right are they
more apathetic than Gen Xers nurses etc
and my whole take on consumers in
general is that people don't necessarily
change over time the world surrounding
them pass and so I think you know Gen
Xers like Millennials have incredible
people and there's laggards and there's
people who are narcissistic and there's
people who are altruistic and everything
in between I think the stakes are higher
now because if a kid sends out an email
and Aaron email or bad social media post
it could affect him or her forever and
that wasn't the case with Gen Xers so I
think that humanity is in a place where
the stakes are higher where change
happens at a rapidly accelerating pace
and I think that the in
act of people's actions have
reverberating impact and reverberating
consequences far beyond what they ever
have before
holy cow the change is moving very very
fast it's only eight in you the rate of
change is only good next time so only
gonna accelerate so it's so important to
have an open mindset to change yeah to
adapting and iterating our own skillsets
to adapt to this exponential technology
that's going on but we're not going
backwards
totally thing it doesn't how it used to
be means nothing because we aren't going
backwards people aren't gonna stop
staring at their phones data isn't gonna
become less important right these things
aren't gonna change so a lot of times I
get businesses saying well isn't that
awful that kids are refreshing their
social media posts with the fervor of a
fortune 500 company and I was like well
was it awful that somebody felt the need
to have a platinum Amex versus the gold
Amex so they could show everybody else
is a more wealthier or having Alexis
versus a Toyota which is made with the
same engine by the same company except
it showcases that you have more wealth
well that was driven in the 80s and 90s
so it's not what's right or wrong it's
just where we are and when I put my
business hat on it's not up to me to
tell people you know to be the moral cop
right I'm telling people where things
are and what you can do about it from a
business perspective to move your
business forward which is what most
people come to me to really achieve I
and I really like your analogies are so
powerful because you just you get tied
into the trajectory of Technology
impacting civilization you go back to
like 80s and you know we can even jump
right into this because I think this is
so important there's a big push that's
happening right now you make this the
similar point that Gen X was super
interested in having a house in the
suburbs yes super interested in the
three 3,000 square-foot house of the
cars and I think Millennials and Gen Z
is are rushing into metropolis is the
charade of class living in shoe box
that's right Apartments yeah on top of
each other and and actually in your post
that you made on LinkedIn I thought it
was so interesting that you even went as
far as to be like yo McDonald's moved to
the suburbs they did and
and they were like oh [ __ ] we're not
getting any of the talent that we need
so then they relocated a brand new
headquarters in the West Loop in Chicago
and now they're gonna be able to attract
that tap that's exactly right or you
have KITT you know Kimberly Clark out in
Neenah Wisconsin you know slowly
starting to realize how we gonna get
millennial talent up to noon at
Wisconsin so they created an innovation
hub in Chicago and at first what starts
to happen there's a lot of their younger
employees that live in Neenah saying
well I want to work out of Chicago for a
month and then they're like well I
actually want to work out of there
permanently and I think companies really
need to take heed so yeah urbanization
is a thing I don't think it's going away
anytime soon it's reflected in the real
estate prices across America to reflect
it in gentrification I live in Brooklyn
real estate prices are up over 100
percent in a 10-year span neighboring
suburbs are up two to five percent the
reason why is when you were a gen Xer
right or you're a baby boomer you really
didn't have a way to see what people
that were 20 years younger than you were
doing so because of that you were at you
were essentially in a rush to grow up
like your contemporaries and you didn't
have any you know elements of youth the
hangman - but shouldn't what those
elements of youth were right but now you
know I have a 13 year old daughter I
know the type of music her and her
friends like because I follow people who
influenced them so when I'm in the car
with them I'm gonna know what to put on
the radio and I'm gonna know what their
friends are gonna like and not only that
I'm gonna want to hold on to that
because I know it's gonna impact the
business relationships again - and my
career trajectory to be in touch with
where things are headed and where things
are evolving isn't in the suburbs it's
in the cities so social media the access
that we have on our mobile device has
really allowed people to understand
where things are headed and that drives
where they live and how they act in it
where they work and how they play and a
lot of that is headed towards the cities
I often talk about my keynotes people
young kids grow up quick but but then
adults grow old slow and their growing
old growing up quickly kids because
they've access to so much information
but the growing old slow because I don't
really find a need to get old in the
traditional sense anymore because they
can hang on to what those elements of
youth are whether it be the trends or
the entertainment acts or the TV shows
or the fashion and style all those
things you can hold on to it because
you understand you have actually of year
into what those things are and wanna
also make this a geopolitical picture
yeah as we're seeing the same
urbanization happening in the major
cities in China oh yeah I just came back
from Europe I was keynoting s ap global
conference of Barcelona and it's
happening all over the world I mean now
obviously when you talk about places
like China and Russia you know with the
state-owned media that happens there a
lot of times they throttle that cultural
growth North Korea is another area where
and more developed markets more
democratic markets like areas of Western
Europe and even some of the emerging
markets like Brazil and South Korea and
India you are seeing that the element
that we're seeing here in the states
become replicated support you talk about
China and Russia it's not necessarily
the case because state-owned media wants
to throttle some of the elements in
which I'm talking about they don't want
you to have the power right so you know
right now in America youth have the
power right you look at TV networks they
don't have the eyeballs the individual
influencers do right I would argue
LeBron James has more power over the
future of his sneakers and Nike does who
makes the sneakers right so those
younger people have the power and that
scares a lot of the countries that don't
believe in a true democracy and because
they are throttling these things that
make this element to come true here in
the United States that's a huge shift
that we went through over the last
couple of decades where it was so that
if you wanted to give any news that you
had to go through an outlet and now with
rice instantaneous a media outlet a
newspaper magazine whatever TV radio but
now it's you have your own Twitter your
own YouTube you have your own way to
disseminate to billions of people
potentially if it goes viral and whatnot
and so that's a huge transition but then
you also identified at the beginning of
the conversation how crazy things are
like what happened with Kevin Hart as
well where people can just dig back 10
years and throw up some sort of a oh
your ethics were bad back then it's like
you isaacs me forever right i evolved as
a human we all evolved as humans a
stupid [ __ ] that i said ten years
yeah we all do I'd love to see them yeah
I mean I think it's that and I think
that it's happening from a tops down and
bottoms up perspective
bottoms up meaning in the 80s and 90s
young people couldn't really formulate
their own brand preferences because the
the whole family would gather around and
watch Cheers or friends on TV right and
they would see the same TV spots that
were you know they were targeted towards
an older demographic because the parents
were making the buying decisions kids
couldn't go on the Amazon and see the
sneakers or the things I actually wanted
to buy so a lot of those buying
decisions were actually made by parents
of course over time you had Michael
Jordan representing Nike and you had
kids winning they gravitate but their
brand preferences in a really you know
change or drive the shopping habits
where today kids are building their own
taste and sophistication and they're
actually adopting technology and
products that their parents will one day
adopt and they're actually becoming the
influences of purchasing in the
household so that's bottoms up and then
tops down like you're talking about
they now have no longer death-room soap
boxes in Times Square to shout to people
you know how they feel about things they
have YouTube where they can actually
from a top-down perspective with scale
that compete through the network drive
the trends themselves so they can adopt
them and they can drive them and really
the adults so to speak are really
following and that's why I call it
euthanasia that's like all my book use
nation it's that premise and it's not
just about age either because you know
you can be any age and adopt these
tendencies it's just that the younger
generation especially the Millennials
grew up with the Internet in the
household their brains are wired
differently yeah and and Gen Z the same
the difference between Gen Y the gen Z
is gonna be nowhere near as stark as if
it seen Gen X Gen Y because it's not
gonna be another internet invented
anytime soon and people who grew up with
the Ada and the household they just have
different brains and that's a huge
divide huge difference between growing
up with the internet and not yeah that's
a big divide I'm happy that you're
identifying that um I would I would I
mean we have so many things to talk
about it would love to stay on that but
I'm sure we're gonna touch on it as we
keep going Matt has this really fun way
of explaining things to people and he's
and he's giving this really profound
and it kind of like hits you a little
bit because cash has been such an
important part of civilization yeah and
all of a sudden the Queen egde in the
dollar village poof yeah
gone and we're seeing it through like
you pointed out 12 years ago we had City
Bank and Bank of America and these
massive conglomerates are the biggest
cat market cat yes
now the Facebook Amazon yellow apples
have the big smart cap and they all
offer payments Ryan they also have more
trust if you ask consumers who they
trust more now that may have changed
with companies like Facebook over the
last six months we're now maybe it's it
shifts because you know I had this whole
graph I put on stage where you know the
tech companies have more trust with
consumers and the banking companies but
there's been a wave of negative
publicity with the Facebook's and the
lesser extent googles of the world where
maybe consumers don't trust them with
knowing where they spend their and how
they spend their money anymore
so it'll be interesting things change so
quickly they even that point from six
months ago may mean I exist but
regardless notion of cash is definitely
going away the notion of having a
physical credit card is going away cuz
you know you look at Apple pay and
you're entering your credit card in your
phone and you just tap your phone so
your credit card becomes your phone so
there's that - yeah we check yen and you
can pay with the override message and of
course it was demo and now there's
cryptocurrency and where that's gonna
happen which I think I make the analogy
of cryptocurrency almost like the
dot-com like in 2000 pets.com and all
these companies they collapse I remember
being at the first company I work for
who had bought my initial startup saying
oh the internet we told you it was just
sort of a fad and then it just came
roaring back and I think that the same
things that happened with cryptocurrency
at the market wasn't ready
governments weren't ready big business
wasn't ready but sooner or later
blockchains gonna have better adoption
more understanding the market will be
ready for it and it's gonna roar back
and and in what form who knows you know
will it be Bitcoin will the blockchain
just power the way that financial
institutions you know interact with
consumers who knows but it's not the
last you're gonna hear about that for
sure yeah
and you you made this really clear point
about the internet being this profound
shift in people in the way that not only
are neural networks in the way that we
behave all around
Society but then you said that there
might not be another one for a little
bit blockchain and and decentralisation
may in fact be this new set of protocols
for the Internet of Things
Fache or FinTech for all different ways
of ensuring safety yeah I look at that
as a layer it's not like a large
ancillary company now I mean before the
internet I couldn't send PO me an email
right I couldn't share content I could I
mean you think of all the things the
internet has replaced and even to a
lesser extent the iPhone has replaced
you know blockchain will impact Commerce
and it'll impact authentication all
these things but it's not gonna have
that sea change of effect that the
internet itself did in my opinion maybe
I'm wrong I mean well it remains to be
seen but that's why I believe worship
we've seen a change unlike no other
would this gap from Gen X Gen Y and
what's interesting about Millennials is
I see a lot of companies saying oh we're
movin on the gen Z I was like well wait
a second Millennials their oldest
Millennials are 38 years old they're
just starting to enter the c-suite
they're just starting to make business
buying decisions but just only become
the CFO of the household now Millennials
actually the real power spending power
and influence actually to move markets
in a way that they never did ten years
ago
so the mind those were just starting to
exert their will and power on the future
of business to future society if it if
culture that and that's what we continue
to see your identity you're identifying
this really interesting way that the the
people in their teens and they're in
their 20s end up taking leadership
positions at companies later on in their
lives and we see the fabric of system
what happens when P&G gets taken over by
miletti what happens in Ford Motors gets
taken over by millennial right like we
don't know yet but that's gonna happen
we're gonna be there closer than we
think
and that's when these big companies are
gonna someone's gonna walk in say not
doing this anymore not spending 80% of
our media budget targeting 18 to 34 year
olds we want to go program programmatic
right we need to figure out how to go
direct to consumer we need to figure out
ways to get first party data you know we
need to have a real sustainability
initiative in the companies not just
throw a pink ribbon onto something and
saying that we're you know it cause
based I mean that that's gonna happen
and when that happens we're really gonna
start to see that shift from a top-down
standpoint when today it's really been
much more bottoms up
Asians yeah you you also have pointed
out that this this is this and I don't
know how far back this goes in history
but that the cycle there's now if it's
the the amount of fortune 500 companies
that are just eight to ten years old
versus the ones that are that have been
there fifty or sixty yes it's crazy and
it's a half of them yeah the average age
of a company in a fortune 500 was fifty
to sixty years old in the 60s and now
it's eight to twelve years old because
there's just so much disruption in M&A
happening where you know these companies
are never gonna be around forever
anymore because of all this disruption
because big tech companies are coming in
and and buying and disrupting you know
institutions that have been around for
centuries so that just shows you the how
the rate of change is adapting I mean
who would have thought that companies
like MySpace would just be come and go
like a blip and snapchat will probably
be the same thing you know there was a
time when no one thought that Facebook
was infallible yeah who knows I mean it
could be broken up by the government
just like how Microsoft had antitrust
issues in the 90s I mean you're gonna
start to see with all these companies
what happens to Google in the world of
voice which I know you want to get into
when I'm searching for the nearest pizza
place on my phone but since Apple has
the last mile of the device in my hand
they can control who delivers the search
so they can put you know commercial
pressure onto Google because I'm not
logging into Google comm anymore what
does that mean all right so there's just
so many questions that are gonna be
arisen by all these new I love ya okay
one quick sub yeah we get to voice there
you you point you pointed this out this
is really important is that we're about
to be where we're seeing thousands of
cryptocurrencies be born and we're only
gonna see a couple more a couple left
down the line look after the.com yeah
and then I also want to say that this is
very interesting because it's also
affecting in ways the way that countries
that are now developing into the
Internet age markets they skipped over
yeah they do the leapfrog don't have
landline phones everywhere they have to
tear down phone poles are going right to
wireless mobile they're going right to
5g so these countries are gonna you know
be like very underdeveloped in some
aspects from an infrastructure
standpoint but it developed in a much
more advanced way in terms of their
fiber optics and and how data gets
spread and it's a crazy dichotomy yeah
that's super interesting to see them
doing the leap frogging and then it's
also crazy to see populations like the
United States and Japan and other places
around the world that have been
developed for a period of time now their
population is stabilizing because
Millennials and Gen Z are choosing to
have just one kid I think of living in
cities they're getting married later to
having children later yeah and even then
it's only one maybe gemo if you're lucky
so the replacement fertility rates
actually below 2 versus in Africa in
many places it's still 5 or 6 yeah per
couple which is which makes Africa's
population pyramids just risqué
rocketing in my youth so they're gonna
be a big part of the creative class and
the college for large companies exactly
and so this is what I wanted to ask do
you see a fight between the Amazon and
Alibaba to supply Africa with with socks
into the pores
yes Attell yeah I mean it was a global
basis you know I was in Sweden last week
and Amazon's just launching in Sweden
right it was mind-blowing because I was
speaking to some people there and
they're saying well the culture here
isn't like what's work on a 24/7 basis
we don't need deliveries the next day
we're not in a rush we don't need
deliveries coming at five o'clock at
night because we're staying down with
our family and we leave work at 4:30 you
know so is Amazon gonna change the
culture of the place like Sweden one
place like Australia or just launched in
2017 when I was there on the speaking
tour it's gonna be really interesting to
see so you have one aspect where you
have Amazon with that which has changed
culture right like I can't go into a
retail and retailer anymore like Best
Buy and stand that more than five
minutes because I would just start doing
that math in my head I'm like oh Ryan
now can I have it there an hour I'm
leaving right I'm just not gonna go
there anymore so change the way I look
at almost every business and looks at
the way change it away with my time so I
think there's a notion of the companies
like Amazon changing culture based upon
them entering a country and yes I mean
where are they going to get their growth
from right I mean they're finding ways
to gain new growth from Prime members of
fluent Prime members in the US but like
most companies they're gonna hit a wall
and the US wanted to have enough
saturation and there
in order to appease their massive
multiples on Wall Street they're gonna
have to go to emerging markets and it's
gonna be a battle to go to places like
Africa South Africa you name it against
the Ali Baba's who has really you know
come up with a very strong footprint
overseas yes
whoa okay um okay let's move into diff t
this is such a cool acronym do it for
the Instagram or get it for the
Instagram and we see a lot of
Millennials and Gen Z moving towards
this experiences that the status update
is the new status Samia and that's such
a cool phrase because we now see private
jets that have never taken off yeah they
just take photos and further private
jets or that people go and get a $24
sundae or they go to the they go to what
it meant a runway or your black talks
where they can just rent it we're short
the next day sure yeah and but that's
also simultaneously talked about the
benefits of that because that's the
shared economy and that's a big benefit
instead of everyone owning yet I under
for ian's but then there's this
obsession with the perfect image in the
trillions of photos of our own yeah
bases it's a little bit of narcissism
mental health issue suicide rates all
the stuff yeah so tell us about yeah I
mean I think well first of all if T
stands for is that it for the Instagram
and what that means is that your online
persona is now so important that and
it's driven by experiences over the
buying of things right because it's a
much better portrayal of the society
about your individual tastes and
interests that people are now pursuing
experience is not only so much to enjoy
them but to prove that they're actually
there so they are going through a
checklist of places around the world
actually travel to like Machu Picchu or
the Eiffel Tower right or the Great Wall
of China and really what they're doing
when they go there's they look at the
most influential people where they've
taken photos and that's where they want
to go and that's also impacting the
hotels they stay at the restaurants that
they eat at etc now the reality is that
in 80's 90's early 2000's people would
lean into brands as a way to showcase
who they were all about you know
American Express membership has its
privileges right or people rushing
towards brands like the gap or FUBU
Benetton in the 80s is sort of like
entrance into a club right if you were a
door
that brand so in my opinion it was no
different it just manifests it
differently people basically used brands
as their social currency that and they
would go after those brands which drove
the rise of consumerism down from the
luxury market to everyday street corners
in the end the birth of shopping malls
etc now brands are so accessible you
know through things like Amazon and
they're becoming cheaper and cheaper
with offshore development that people
have moved towards experiences which if
you think about before Instagram you
couldn't share experiences with anything
but a photo album so they weren't
scalable as a social currency now they
are so people are now prioritizing
experiences over the accumulation of
physical thinks which is driving them to
travel more than ever before which is
driving them to say if I'm gonna spend
my time and my money it needs to be
something that's the experience when I
could actually capture what are the
downsides to me it's no different in the
downsides of people working hard so they
can get you know a name-brand piece of
clothing versus a store brand piece of
clothing so other people would think
that they're fashionable so I don't
necessarily now the difference is it's
more instant it's more accessible and
there's long-term reverberations you
know the instant gratification dopamine
of how many likes that you get that's
saying that we never had before so as I
mentioned earlier in this interview the
stakes are higher than ever before so
it's more of the same and I would argue
that of gen-xers how to Instagram they
would be treating it the same way so
it's not necessarily the generation but
it's this technology you look at the
airplanes people said that the airplanes
would take people away from their
families right because before it you
couldn't travel I have two brothers that
live on the west coast it sucks right
but they were able to pursue their
dreams and actually move out there and
allowed you to come travel here to
interview me today right so I think with
every evolution of society there's going
to be negativity right but I think
ultimately progression in a civilized
humanity isn't gonna stop driverless
cars are going to kill people but so do
it
so do car traffic accidents every day it
doesn't mean we don't pursue it and
that's my general thought on that yeah
and that's super powerful it's we're
very grateful for the fact that there's
almost 200,000 of these commercial
flights that happen every single world
it took people a long time to see a bird
make a plane
yeah nowadays people ride the plane and
they throw the idea away like a coffee
cup or we can
the Wi-Fi is not good enough it's
ridiculous and okay you you highlighted
a bunch of important stuff I just want
you to tell us about what do you think
about the the struggle with the mental
health rights yeah so I think the
struggle with mental health issues is
real and it's something that both
corporations and more importantly
parents need to get their arms around
and it's not easy you know speaking of a
father of two children that are gems
ease you know Jen's ears I can say that
when you take their phones away from
them their argument which is a good one
is you're taking me away from my friends
you're taking the other social circles
you're disabling my ability to become
you know part of groups and and and
friendships and it's hard to make an
argument against it at the same time
there's real addiction there's a real
personal validation that comes across
with how you post you know a picture and
how people actually pursue it
there's not really a magic bullet some
parents and educators that imagine
people saying take their phones away
from them right but I would make the
argument if you did that by the time
they get into college they're gonna be
so far behind in terms of things that
they know right and their ability to
actually intuitively use this technology
to further their career right there's
some parents and educators that will say
let them do whatever they want but I
would argue that these young you know
developing emotions and brains really
can't deal with such a powerful toll so
it is about moderation is about tools
like Apple has screen time which you
know allows you to manually block you
know what people are kids are seeing and
how long they're seeing it for and it's
really about the school's embracing it I
think that you know the education system
is so far behind and I think that the
kids know more about technology and the
teachers too and I think that you know
they don't they're not in a position to
be able to probably educate kids on how
to really use this powerful tool and it
is creating a lot of men and health
issues especially with Gen Z because Gen
Z it's evolved more and more as
basically the center of their world
where it may have been a powerful tool
for Gen Y and that's why you're saying
the pressure rates and things like that
it's really skyrocket you know with with
this younger generation and it's a real
problem that we need to deal with just
like hell cigarettes are a problem
we need to deal with when they came out
and I think that there's gonna be a low
point as there was with lung cancer and
cigarettes and there'll be a turning
point and you know there'll be
regulation and things like that that
will come into play and that's how I see
this thing going but it's not going away
anytime soon because unlike cigarettes
you know arguably which I believe
there's way more benefits for society
for mobile devices and the internet and
connected devices and I think that
businesses are relying on the strong of
our economy I mean without Google and
Facebook and Apple and Amazon where's
the US economy right now that's right
right where's the growth coming from
where the job growth coming from what's
a tax base will coming from
so that's why you can't just pull that
out totally totally mm-hmm I want out
out to organizations like the Center for
Humane Technology where we're literally
trying to figure out how to make the
best vehicle designs Marc Benioff been a
big proponent of handling the inequality
is so that we see in our and our daily
lives and this is a lot being propagated
by the entrance of major corporations
into a heavily populated areas by normal
everyday retail workers and and yeah etc
so okay I want to jump into this this
directly ties to the big land grab
that's happening right now in the
attention economy so the kids have to be
on the devices because there have to be
growing their audiences because they
know there's a zero-sum game that's
being played there's seven point seven
billion people about 16 waking hours per
day for every person yeah that's just
over a hundred twenty billion hours of
collective human attention per day
that's a zero it's a zero-sum game
Facebook Google Apple Marissa everyone's
a ten cent Alibaba Baidu they're all
trying to get big pieces of the cake and
then the YouTube or performers or
directors yes so what we do with this
attention to read the race for right
well yeah so 120 billion hours is true
but as a businessperson I could say
there's probably you know 300 hours of
attention that if I achieve running my
startup will make the difference between
you know having an amazing year or just
an okay year right so I don't need the
world's attention
I need the world I think the attention
of the people the potential buyers of my
software that's right right so I think I
think that gets lost in the
just like trying to collect I remember
somebody on Twitter once said to me like
oh you will you will don't have a big
presence on YouTube
you only have 500 subscribers and and
but I know that the average view time of
my videos on YouTube is 8 minutes and
those 500 people are people who can make
or break my year
I don't need tens and thousands or
millions of subscribers I am a very
niche business person and that's where I
actually come on trying to win a
popularity contest
alright on am sure so I think that
everybody can look at it in that way so
it's not a bet so so that who matters
and what's the what's the real
scoreboard that matters during the day
and in business obviously some people
think it's freedom or financial success
personally it's deep and meaningful
relationships it's usually people don't
usually derive you know true happiness
from having more and more followers or
don't even know and I think that that
narrative needs to be completely
reinforced you know if my top that's 25
friends in the world really care about
something that I'm sharing that's
meaningful to me that matters way more
than having 5,000 people who I never see
like it right I mean that's the reality
this is a crucial point you you're
you're tying into the the Preta
principle into the into F into the
attention economy and into our friends
aren't our relationships everything that
we should be parsing all of the existing
information identifying the 20% of
customers or information and only 20
will right yeah that we need to find
that 20% and find those 20% of customers
of meaningful relationships etc and go
for those so it's not actually about
trying to build up millions of followers
that don't even care really it's more
about identifying the best now there's
some people I give your coca-cola and
you service all of humanity you do need
the biggest audience as possible right
and you have the resources and time to
actually dedicate towards that if you're
Matt Britten consultant right or map
written CEO well you don't you there's
if you are a pharmaceutical sales person
right there's probably 300 doctors out
there that will make or break your year
you need to focus on having them follow
you and see how you can add value to
them because that if you're doing it for
business purposes
that's what's gonna move the needle
right and I feel like how Instagram
actually just launched like the close
friends feature because that's a good
example of
I don't want to share my intimate parts
of my life and my family life with
everybody who follows me just probably
200 people that I do want to and I think
that's kind of a step in that direction
I'm literally playing piano or watching
a video on youtube of someone playing a
piano they have the data to say you have
three friends in your city that play
piano that can teach you how to play
piano there's so many ways to design the
tech tip yeah to be better for humanity
and values ok future of technology this
is crazy that we don't even where the
kids aren't learning handwriting as much
anymore we're learning typing well they
still are there are yeah handwriting but
it's not as quarter the curriculum is it
one thing there's no cursive yeah
there's way less cursive that's for sure
and now yeah the court of the curriculum
is typing coding designing art science
etc but even you say typing is going
away because we're going to voice we
have the Amazon Alexa the Google Holmes
yeah etc and then Siri Siri exactly and
furthermore what's crazy is that then
for example if I use Amazon order
batteries there's Amazon basics yeah
then there's Duracell and all the other
companies so now they get to choose if
they want to put their products up their
words so voice is very interesting yeah
we're gonna control our lives by right
yeah I mean you you you touched on a
couple of different points when you
talked about education right and as I
mentioned earlier I mean I think
education is probably the sector that's
in the most dire need of reinvention yes
moving for you look at the categories
that have been laggards in terms of
their disruption it's health care its
financial services and education and you
know I think that financial services
getting there I mean one of the
positives coming out of the Trump
administration and I'm not in the
politics but he definitely was very
strong at the regulation which has had
positive and negative impacts more than
the positive impacts is to really open
up a lane for FinTech to come in and
actually disrupt that category a lot
more quickly which is interesting to see
but in terms of Education
there's been no such regulation and
there's been no such change and largely
we're teaching kids the same things that
we were 20 years ago you know does it
make sense to teach kids algebra when I
can actually just ask Susie to compute a
problem for me
now the proponents would say yeah but
going through the notion of the probe of
the problem makes more sense and I would
say well you can do that on a macro
basis and skips stitch problems together
that can come up with a bigger answer
versus getting into the context of that
one individual equation because you
don't need to do it anymore
right so it's so much notion work I can
drive a car but I don't know how to
actually assemble a vehicle right
because I don't need to that's actually
done for me and I just need to know how
to drive it right so I think a lot of
the things are based upon what people
need it to know how to do before
technology was here and in the more
developed markets they're skipping over
that right and kids are learning things
that are gonna put those students in a
globally competitive environment far
ahead of students in America because we
are holding on to the past of what it
means for education and I think that you
know I think College is in so many ways
harming kids from pursuing their dreams
they they look at how things were done
and they're pursuing four-year education
but they're getting in debt to do it and
then they leave and they were they
realize well I can't pursue my dream I
need to try to get a job at Goldman
Sachs or a white-shoe all for him so I
can pay back my student loans they get
married they have a mortgage or they
have like a high overhead and that dream
gone forever right they can never do it
so what's it all for right and I think
that really needs to change as well in
terms of voice I think voice is very
powerful I think that that last mile
effect where whoever has that weird
weird device if the car was gonna have a
renewed important 2019 and beyond you
know the the dissemination of Alexa
devices in a home has put Amazon in the
real position is strange when it comes
to branding and brand equity you know
when you try to order well involvement
items whether it be cell phone chargers
or a batteries or you have it you can
essentially ask Amazon and they're gonna
revert to their own products where they
have higher margins and a lot of
consumers are going to buy because they
trust Amazon just as much as they trust
P&G and it's much easier to order from a
device where you don't have to pick up
your phone then this actually log into
something in search for tide that's
right and now all of a sudden what
happens to the brand equity of ad or
seller energizer who spent billions and
hours and good
I'm doing their brand equity it kind of
goes away so as I mean for the future of
brand they do a lot of these company to
get into hardware like I say all the
time if you make dishwasher detergent
right or laundry detergent you should
buy a company that makes you know
laundry machines and instead of trying
to sell the PNG try to sell your laundry
machines which are smart and only order
your tied product sell those to the big
developers of you know buildings and
major cities and you have intravenous
sales model because you don't have to
rely on people going into Walmart and
actually picking out your brand from a
slew of other brands and oh by the way
Walmart's his own private label brands
so I think that's that's where a lot of
us needs to change I think the job of
the CMO is no longer will even about
brand building anymore it's about really
building ecosystems and more to their
product and actually thrive in a way
that's just beneath the surface not
basically trying to send themselves
people get a couple inches of shelf
space at Target or Walmart that's a huge
change change yeah yeah and you also
referenced a huge change of having the
massive iPads on the walls a touch touch
design yeah engineering all up on the
wall visions I'm televisions up on the
walls even projections and spatial
intelligence spatial computing with
companies like magically pin all the XR
the VRA are tech that we see in emerging
that we are totally where were human
animals that love to be able to move and
play with the space in front of us to
send the emails and to build things here
in with an augmentation in our vision
and our touch ability so we're totally
moving into that space as well and
that's cool because it makes it furthers
that location agnosticism that's right
yeah so yeah I mean I think you know
touched on a couple points I think but
television I think we're gonna start to
see a change in at CES this year earlier
this month you saw Apple for the first
time kind of tear down its walls and say
okay Samsung you can now integrate
Airplane iTunes right into your devices
because what they're starting to
understand is that especially in
developed markets like here in America
they've really hit a saturation point
with the sales of iPhone how are they
going to drive growth was through data
and content and how they gonna do it by
actually distributing their data and
content not just through their iPhones
or not just people who buy their ad on
Apple TV device but for
tens or hundreds of millions of people
out there who have Samsung TVs now of a
sudden you could distribute to them and
when that happens you're going to start
to see the the power and programmatic
nature of iTunes actually start to
integrate seamlessly with television
device it is at what point I think
you're gonna see TV has become a giant
iPad on your wall because kids go up to
TVs and they try to swipe them right and
they they don't know what a TV network
is US and where ABC is okay to alphabet
you have some of Fox's your toes you
they'll tell you it's an animal right
they're not tuning in the TV networks
are tuning into people yeah right people
are brands friends are people and in
that world what happens when P&G wants
to spend you know six billion dollars on
television around the world like where
are they gonna want to spend it because
they can no longer buy into these broad
18 to 34 Nielsen based demographics
they're gonna have to go after little
pieces of of consumers text but their
competitors are going to be doing and
they're not built for it so I think
that's super interesting in terms of
what's gonna happen when television and
the medium marketing and advertising
space which I know quite well but yeah I
mean you talked about you know spatial
technology and spatial computing and you
know the phone itself I think is gonna
start to go away in the next five to
seven years I don't think the notion of
all of us having a thrown around is
going to be something that is going to
be commonplace with citizens of this
country because if you think about the
Apple watch already announced that you
can walk out and take a phone call just
with your watch right I think that
contact lens is with 5g and the power of
computing where I can basically see
information about you by just telling my
lens hey Siri show me where that guy
went to college and then having it
overlay on top of you or when I'm
driving which whether I turn in the map
overlays over your eyes I think that's
the future of the phone it's gonna be
interesting to see where that goes as
well the way that the technologies are
entering our world and the way that
we're preparing ourselves for the entry
of these technologies is really
important the way that we aim to
equalise make the baseline of of
equality of opportunity high for
everyone around the world to enable
their full creative potential so crucial
yeah Matt here we are at Susie's office
yes I love what you're doing with Suzy
and I think so many other people are
going to be really
excited about this I was a know a really
good way to just introduce this is how
cool is it to be able to as an
organization send a poll to a diverse
1.2 million people right now our
consumers on Suzy which are actually
getting paid for answering these
questions will tell you in a moment and
that there's a question from an
organization that gets launched maybe
it's a question like which music
streaming services do you use and then
they will reply to that organization in
real time with interests instantly yeah
they'll get a reply then the
organization will know okay well it
looks like a majority of people are
using Spotify in this country there's
something and more granular it's an it's
not just in this country it's it looks
like people who chose Spotify or 18 to
34 live in a major market and have a
household income of X that's why or they
also like Nike you know or the people
like Spotify also tend to like this logo
there than that logo so the beauty of
the the super panel that we built is we
have dozens and dozens of pieces of
first-party data on these people you
know we know their household income we
know their brand preferences we know
where they live their mouth status
they're in you know the education says
etc so we can overlay that data as well
as the data of third-party companies and
we also don't share any first party data
so in a world of privacy concerns when
our clients get the results
it says Joe 18 years old from Minnesota
but you don't see Joe's last name you
don't know who Joe actually is so we
don't share any PII but we share that
Anonymous audience profile which enables
that decision-making this is so the
future of getting real-time actual data
there uw have a funny
it's the highest Popo highest paid
person's opinion yeah I mean that's what
I experienced in agency world running
mister youth flush mry for 12 years is I
saw these CMOS make decisions based upon
their own personal guesses or their own
personal myopic experiences their
daughter likes his band so let's
sponsors ban these multi-million dollar
decisions and tiny decisions built to
multi-million dollar decisions were made
with no data behind it they were just
made by hunches and guesses and in a
world where all these big companies are
stressing data-driven decision making
yeah you know this is something that can
very easily empower that so you
the voice of your consumer at every step
of the way and as these copies currently
are run by non millenials I'm trying to
cater to a new world it's more important
than ever before that they have the
voice of consumers you know in their
mind at every decision and it doesn't
mean they need to listen you know it's
like the whole notion that Henry Ford
said if I lessened the consumers I would
have you know you sold a faster horse
like I get that but I think there's so
many instances where consumers will
actually make you rethink things or or
go into a new direction that you haven't
gone into in the past and it's what
Susie is is really just the voice of the
consumer encapsulate it in a very easy
tool you can deploy and we're deploying
it
we have over 130 organizations large and
small big companies like Microsoft P&G
J&J are using it and smaller mid-market
and even startups are using it to really
drive the decision-making and it's been
it's been a great ride yeah and it's
really interesting that you can both
pull and ask audiences about things like
what kind of packaging design do you
prefer for our for our item and then
they can give you an answer to that they
can also submit written reply so you can
ask for open-ended you happen and we
also can have em reply to actually
physical product to stimulus so
companies could send 200 product samples
that aren't on the market yet and
actually have people respond in terms of
would you buy this product and then once
you get that feedback you can see what
are the correlations between the people
who do want to buy it or do they live
what are their other preferences you can
start to build that really deep
segmentation if you're gonna go to
market with and market research has been
something that hasn't really evolved
it's been you know very expensive and
time-consuming to conduct and because it
isn't accessible a lot of people just
don't use it at all so you're kind of
throwing out the baby with the bathwater
we're now actually we have a way it's
very lightweight intuitive that allows
people to you know really deploy this
tool to get again the voice of the
consumer behind the decision making this
is instantaneous ABCDs ting and it's
also cool because you can retarget the
probably right so you get you oh you get
statistical significance during the same
beating you're in so I can ask a
question have 500 people respond before
the beating us up so like that's how
quickly because we will actually want to
have this tool deliver at the pace of
business and pace of culture the pace of
decision making
and then since all the Danna's are on
first party data if Joe Smith says I
like this product but I feel like that
the leather actually sticks to my ankles
I wouldn't buy the sneaker we actually
go back to Joe Smith and digging deeper
yeah you know target yeah once I get
those exact same people and also every
questions completely anonymous so you
can do competitive testing and things of
that nature as well so it's been a great
ride I mean we have an amazing team and
our team is super dedicated and believes
in what we're doing and obviously we
have our work cut out for us
you know competing against major you
know multi-billion dollar companies so
like Qualtrics which just sold to SAPD
for a billion dollars I mean those are
companies that really paved the way for
us which we've got to respect but we
think what we have is really unique and
we're really excited about our prospects
for 2019 and then let's quickly mention
that they also the consumers that answer
these questions they earn points yeah
and then they're able to redeem the for
charity or products yeah it's a game a
fight system I mean like all market
research or like any time a company
engages with consumers for feedback
their time is valuable you need to
compensate them for them you know the
rub with us is making sure that people
are also giving the honest feedback and
they're not just doing it for the points
and we've developed a lot of game
mechanics behind it as well of quality
control measures to ensure that the
answers are significant and are
representative of the broader population
so we'll test our answers against other
tools that might take 30 days to deliver
the same results and as long as our
results match right then we have a
better mousetrap so to speak
and we're doing a lot of work on that
right now as well man that's so tough
that actually puts you into a category
that I think is similar to Facebook and
YouTube and Twitter and whatnot where
they actually have to go and make sure
there's not videos up of someone killing
someone else yeah the gun or thank you
yeah yeah we have a whole team that's on
quality control yeah we do tell me about
it I still have time for you though yeah
well hopefully what the resultant of
your the last thing I'll say about Suzy
the results are only Anna degrade we
have over 80 percent renewal rate with
our clients or clients who have used it
for a year over four out of five times
they will renewing and there we going
for one or two more years which is great
signs of software company and it's also
saying I use for myself for all my
thought leadership my blog post things I
want to understand about the consumer
Suzy is my best friends and
you know and helping me understand where
the consumers had it which has been
great
and will we be able to pull our
individual audiences as content creators
soon yes and yeah you can ask yes the
audience yeah yeah bringing your own
audience and have feedback come in and
interest absolutely so like a little
simulation exactly ready and have people
come here disclosing our product roadmap
to the millions of people on the
electric show yes to the hopefully
couple it just needs to be the right
people right yeah that's right that's
right it needs to be the right people
that help move it along with that amount
okay I want to ask quick about this
what's up with the we talked about this
a lot during the show but I want to get
maybe a concrete principle from you in
this sense what would be a crucial
principle for children and for parents
to teach their children about the future
of work with the gig economy and yeah
there's an AI biotech Neurotech
blockchain all these explosions
explosive fields yeah what's a couple
corporates sure I mean it's interesting
CNBC has a story in December that Google
alphabet Corp the parent company owns
Google actually had more independent
contractors working on their business
and employees and that's really
fascinating because it shows that Google
won the obviously most forward-thinking
companies on earth is saying we don't
need to actually have full full-time
workforce to drive our business because
you know we have seasonal fluctuations
and we have varying needs over time so
we need to tap into different resources
at different times and we want to be
lightweight as organization we won't be
able to be dynamic
you see Microsoft starting to do the
same thing and I think most progressive
companies are going to start to realize
that just having a team of full-time
employees isn't the solution and you
need to actually have an Augmented
resource pool of people that can fit
very specific needs of very specific
times and that's why you see this gig
economy really exploding that's why you
see we work five either twenty billion
dollars because individuals are learning
at the same time maybe my best path out
of college isn't that go work for a big
company and work my way up the c-suite
especially because the average age of
accompanying the fortune 500 is going
down maybe I need to actually go very
deep into a specialized skill set which
I could offer to these companies work
out of we work and read to find a new
version of the American Dream which is I
can work from anywhere I want
right I can
I have unlimited income opportunities no
boss is going to decide my future I in
decide my future and you're starting to
see this really take off and I would
definitely have my kids focus on that
because it really puts the the power in
their own hands you see people that work
the companies for 20 years and then the
company has a bad year there's nothing
to do with them and they get laid off
right and they're back at square one
how's that right right and that's not
the power in your own hands so I think
you need to have a specialized skill set
what I often say is go deep into an art
or deep into a science going to you can
own art learn how to be a writer learn
how there be a designer on how to be
creative in ways that machines never can
or go deep into a science when I had a
build code and operate the machines
right but if you are jack of all trades
master of none your jobs gonna be
outsourced their offshore to India or
Costa Rica or China and you're gonna
find yourself you know stuck in the
middle with no real opportunity for
expansion in this new world quickest to
that last point it's interesting on the
writing side of things we're already
seeing machines writing which is kind of
interesting yeah
then on the on the on the on the
polymath side knowing a lot about a lot
of different things I think what's
interesting about that is it really
enables the multidisciplinary we've is
across industries that a lot of other
people that are deep in industry can't
see how biotech and blockchain actually
have a lot of significant overlap and
relating DNA more but but if you're an
expert in either yeah yeah I mean like I
know where some people just know a
little bit about everything and not
anything deep and if that's the case
you're not gonna be about a month
monetize our go deep into anything so
can maybe think about it like if you are
to at the surface level right versus if
you're at the cutting edge but if you
know a lot about allotted right cutting
colleges that's a good yeah but it okay
yeah because because I think a lot of
people that think they can leave college
just saying oh I spend a little bit of
everything it's like well why if I'm a
company it's like well you're telling me
that you have to wait for me to tell you
what to do every single day well you
know I'm gonna tell somebody in Costa
Rica to do every day because they're a
tenth of your price yeah and if they're
just gonna follow directions I'll just
tell them to do it you gotta have
initiative this is holding any point
yeah um okay on the way out couple
questions yes this one's about the
geopolitical situation with Millennials
and Gen Z do you see something different
at all formulating in the middle
China South America Europe in terms of
Millennials and you I just think they
feel empowered you look at the Arab
Spring you will get all these revolts
again against government you the Turkish
coup d'etat being it's happening or the
attempted coup d'etat in Turkey is it's
happening everywhere is that people
using technology as you know people say
it spread people further apart I've made
the argument more so it sparked people
closer together it's empowered people
it's exposed the truth and it's made
younger people think that they are in
control of their future now sometimes it
has drastic negative consequences right
because there's only so much they can do
against big government but in truly
democratic societies it does empower
people and it does empower people to
have a voice you see these huge women's
marches or gun violence marches that
happen Washington DC with the Parkland
students I mean that would never been
that happen 10-15 years ago so I think
it's a great thing but the question is
especially in America it's great you do
these things but are you gonna come out
and vote right are you got you're gonna
what are you what else you gonna do
about it he's gonna become an
entrepreneur yeah you're gonna news Jack
and actually just jump on things that
are interesting at the time or are you
really gonna become somebody who's an
activist yeah and actually continue to
drive and and try to you know drive
change where you live because a lot of
people just go very surface in that as
well it seems like with data were we're
moving with this big data silos we're
moving more into letting the data flow
so decentralizing the data and maybe
that comes with some encrypting so that
way it's anonymized and whatnot but at
the same time there's a big movement for
this radical transparency in data saying
that I don't really care if you know
that I'm in New York right now I can
know that I'm in New York and I'm 26 and
then I make this much money a year I
don't really care my heart rate you know
you can still I get attacked by somebody
who knows that you're outside your house
and they go rob you right so it's like
the problem with that is transparency
and data works until the it gets
transparent to people who didn't intend
for it to be transparent to so we have
to then build trust for so we have to we
have to evolve our own ethics and morals
first to not commit malevolence against
each other and then we can have that
router but I don't think that's I hope
that gets realistic cuz anything yeah it
there I think there's good and bad
people and I think
there's gonna be people always bad
actors and I think it's more about data
security I think you look at GD P R and
you will get upset and you look at all
these initiatives to basically protect
people's data and I think that you know
blockchain is gonna be a big part of
that I think that's more important
because there's always gonna be bad
actor he's always gonna need lots on
your front door
first I believe interesting yeah let's
um let's see if we if maybe if we didn't
have to stick up so fast in population
where there was this massive inequality
with education right and ignorance right
we could have potentially kept it at
we're evolving trust and ethics maybe
I'm a beauty though it's a little
idealistic because throughout time I
feel like it's always been that way
class you know yes who knows where we'll
get I like that point okay now what
would you say has been the core driving
principle of your life of my life
yeah I think I embrace risk and I think
I invest in my investment myself and
trust the future
so there's many decisions I've made that
at that time many outsiders looked as
probably not the smartest move at that
time but I knew that if I actually put
in the work that it would pay off in the
future and I think I'd rather go down
investing in myself then take the easy
road and playing it safe and and that
really has impact that all aspects of my
life I just I'm confident about my
impact on people and on business and and
the commercials and everything else that
comes out of it that I will always take
risks like go work at a startup and
leave a cushy position you know at a big
company I'll always you know make that
choice because I want to make the best
impact and I don't want to leave
anything on the fields when it's all
said and done I love that okay how about
if you could rebuild civilization from
scratch how would you design it did you
think is this one question I heard the
other day if you redistribute it all the
wealth equally how long would it take
for it to get back in the same people's
hands right and I actually believe it
would ultimately work its way
maybe not Jeff Bezos would have what he
has right but I think that those he
would be on the wealth your side and
other people wouldn't the baseline would
come up yeah I mean there's a lot of
things I would do I mean
I believe that you know I would redesign
the way that weapons are available to
people because I think that's a major
issue I would redesign the healthcare
system I would redesign the education
system I think those are those are
things that are changing humanity very
quickly and you know obviously found a
much broader perspective how countries
work with each other and how countries
can get along and you know try to solve
bigger issues like like war you know
what I mean I think that cancer is a
huge issue like what's the role of
Technology and you know creating a cure
for cancer and where do technologies
like CRISPR come into play I mean that's
a huge existential question obviously
but it was just some of things that came
off the top of my head
and would you say that this is a
simulation this this life yeah you know
I back and forth on that you know I
don't know if we're just a bubble as
part of a larger larger bubble I think
that you know we only know what we know
and we are very like we don't only know
we know until we're no longer on this
earth so I think in some ways it almost
doesn't matter because likely it's not
going to change the way that we act
every day maybe for some people it does
where they think that we're just a speck
in something larger so it's gonna they
will be more risk-taking they will be
more loving they won't take things as
more seriously but I think ultimately
we're never probably gonna know in our
lifetime if it is a simulation or not so
all we can do is try to live our ideals
while we're here and see where it takes
us we're hacking it we're hacking into
the code to figure it out yeah yeah and
we're gonna make our own simulations of
what it's like for a rock to evolve
civilization and then we'll see our own
selves potentially yeah last question
yes what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world I guess
love I guess like human interaction
interpersonal relationships you know I
think people going out of their way to
help other people for the love of
humanity it's probably the most
beautiful thing in the world you know
with no monetary gain or no personal
gain just people helping just to help I
think is probably it
if we can all dose up on love we can get
to that unity more easily together
right on Matt Matt EB Matt Britton
this isn't such a Bonner simulator thank
you so much yeah thanks for coming back
thank you thank you everyone thank you
so much for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
things that we talked about just links
let us know exactly check out the links
in the bio I would love for you to check
out Matt's YouTube channel cuz he's got
really powerful 1 minute long Plus also
longer form videos for you to check out
there and also check out the ask Susie
comm or just Susie comlink also below
and go and use it because it is super
insightful go and check it out we could
maybe do some sort of a code potentially
we'll explore that will let you know and
also go and build the future everyone go
and manifest your destiny into the world
go and create we love you so much keep
supporting epic people like Susie like
simulations so we can continue doing
cool things like coming outside and
doing these interviews much love and
we'll see you soon take care
peace that's it my man
great that's awesome I'm glad you had a
good time